thank you very much tori
for the nice introduction and also for
the invitation to speak at this workshop
yes uh so basically uh i understand that
many of you just came from europe and
steal a jet lag so i decided to take it
easier
so not to go much into technical things
and just
and also will try to wake you up with
some open problems and actually there
will be a lot of open problems which i
will try to propose here
and the title of my talk is fine grain
complexity and somehow this is a
little bit uncorrect title because uh
there was some
some part of the title was lost during
the communication
actually the title was fine-grained
complexity of exact algorithms on graphs
but when you have a very long title
usually things become
wrong and actually with our seminar if
you noticed or
with our program now it's become not
fine gain complexity program but i think
it's become now
fine pro just fine program or that's how
it's called
okay but the the story of the stalker or
the idea of the stock goes to july
so i had a very strange communication
with daniel marks
so he just in skype he wrote by the way
what about
a long talk on the end power and
business
and there was some also an entire joke
uh assuming you can get there before
november 7.
but actually yeah so basically
it takes some time to understand what
danielle means by end to the end
business but then uh and probably the
right name of this talk should be just
on uh
end to the end business okay so on
end to the end business talk
of exact algorithms on graphs
so what i will speak today so i will
first try to motivate while
why at all we are doing this type of
research why it's interesting and
basically one of the main mutations we
try to beat brute force
so i will speak about who is this brute
force and why we want to beat
this brute force and then i will speak
about homomorphisms subgraph
isomorphisms
and some consequences which results for
these problems have on
our understanding of graph algorithms
and
we will be there will be some conclusion
and what i will try to do there will be
a lot of a lot of a lot of open
questions problems
open questions and problems okay so just
let's uh
well start with
this motivation so we know this famous
slogan that god created men right and
some cult made them all
equal so probably not appropriate joke
here
but god also created problems right and
np completeness theory also made all of
them equal
and of course it's uh not true because
if you take any area of algorithms
so if if you walk in approximation
algorithms of course we know that not
all problems which i complete are equal
right
some problems are good to approximate
and some problems are
not so good after approximate the same
things uh in parameterized complexity we
know that there are some nice problems
and
there are a lot of not so nice problems
and uh similar things uh going for
heuristics and actually if you take any
area of algorithms probably that will be
the same story
so not all problems are equal and the
approach
which i want to discuss today is the
the most probably the most naive of the
approaches
like if you compare with approximation
algorithms or parameterize complexity
so basically we want to see if
we can improve brute force directly
so and then the whole area of this
algorith of this algorithm is
first people try to improve brute force
and then uh try to improve their
algorithms trying to get better
algorithms but first of all
yes and maybe i just also will quote
remind give a romantic quota scott
aronson who writes about also beating
brute force
we want to know how much better can we
do than blindly searching for the
answers to the very hard computational
problems yes so what is
uh this poor brute force which we want
to beat all the time
right and so this is
so brute force is also in uh like people
call it exhaustive search or
in russian it's called peribor and
basically this is uh
trying all possible kind of uh solutions
or trying all possible options
and uh but if you start thinking about
that what does it mean we try to
all possible options or well one of the
natural things uh what what is the brute
force for np complete problem
so every anti-complete problem it has a
polynomial
it can be certified in polynomial time
so one of the natural
assumptions what is the brute force
doing well we just try to go through all
compact representations of the problem
and if we find the good one we say
yes if we didn't find we just conclude
with that
so basically that's can be one of the
definition
what is a brute force but then even with
this type of definition if you go to
algorithms
it's become a little bit unclear for
example if you speak about click
so for click certificate a kind of
natural it's just a subset of your
decision i i take substitute of yourself
i check if it's a click in polynomial
time
and proceed to another subset of
vertices of the graph but for example
for hamiltonian cycle
what will be certificate so here i can
say well a certificate can be a sequence
of viruses
and then i will have like something like
n factorial
certificates and the other certificate
can be the number of ages right or a set
of ages i can try subsets of ages
and then and check if this is a cycle
or not even here it's a little bit
ambiguous what is a certificate and what
is the brute force
but basically i will try to avoid this
philosophical question
and basically in graph algorithms a kind
of a common agreement is that
we always measure complexity at least
for this type of algorithms
as the number of vertices in a graph so
this
agreement which i will try to follow at
this talk
and this area is quite also actually one
of the first results can be a result of
now it's uh the classic of tribal
assessment problem of two to the n
of health and carb from 1962.
so there are so in 1976 lawler gave an
algorithm for graph coloring
and an even better algorithm from three
coloring so here and so n
is the number of years in a graph or the
number of cities
one should visit so people are working
on sat on independence set
and during this time so there are
appearing new
and better algorithms so there was
improvements for and this actually
not probably the cut of the age
results here so they were improving for
threesat
for coloring there was a breakthrough in
2006 when
people managed to go this is andreas
torre and mikko
who managed to go to the end
there was a walk on trivia some tree
coloring again there was quite technical
improvement of bagel and epstein
for independent set for bandwidth and of
course
another breakthrough result was the
result of andreas on
hamiltonicity which breaking this uh
result from 1962. so
beating this result yes so
while the area was developing quite uh
for a long time
i think uh a strong push to this uh
area was given by gerhard foldinger who
wrote a very influential
survey so this survey is from 2003 and
after the story appears
there was a lot of interest again to
this type of algorithms people start
working on that
and in the survey gerhard classified
problems in
three types of he tried to classify the
problems into
three different sets so one is a
type of problems is a subset problem
basically when we want to find
we have a universe and we want to find a
subset of elements in this universe we
satisfy some property
again clique or assad is subset
problems permutation problems uh it's
when we want to find the
permutation of the objects and again
hamiltonicity is
one of the characteristic problems here
and partition problems when we
have a set of elements and we want to
find a partition which also satisfies
specific properties
so here example is graph coloring and if
we look
at the brute force for these problems
then of course for subset problem the
brute force is taken two to the end time
for permutation problems is n factorial
and for partition problems
and to the end but luckily enough and
what is interesting
that uh very often uh for different
types of problems like
for hamiltonian cycle while brute force
is n of or n factorial
you can go below 2 to the n but can you
go below or
or or you can go below n factorial but
can can you go
below n factorial for every permutation
problem
this is somehow not clear and for some
problems you can do the same you can say
for partition problems
well but uh so far most of the research
was uh
in this area of algorithms was
concentrated on subset problems
and for this type of problem some
people invented or used
techniques from classical algorithms and
there are a lot of development on how to
do clever
branching how to analyze algorithms so
there are very specific uh
techniques developed for these exact
algorithms like split and count
algorithm dynamic programming of course
was used and to obtain
faster algorithms local search
like the showing result on uh
satisfiability
and of course uh for many problems uh
people
managed to prove that brute force is
beatable and actually there was quite
clever improvement of these results
and for some problems like
satisfiability
despite of all type of results uh
there's still
there's no indication that we can
significantly beat
a brute force and for example for such
problem people become so disparate that
even now we start using
uh hypothesis which is called
strong eth which basically said that you
cannot solve
sat with n variables faster than 2 to
the n roughly
speaking somehow so still
there are a lot of things which are
unclear even for subset problems and
there are still a new techniques
appearing
so i will allow myself a spoiler of
daniel talk
so daniel will be speaking about and
also a new technique how to use
parameterized algorithms
to design exact exponential algorithms
but that's
okay but
what makes algorithms cool somehow
right so as a as the people who doing
algorithms
of course when we design algorithms we
are happy we invented a new algorithmic
techniques
we are very happy we solve long-standing
open problems and algorithms again very
nice
but somehow why i think that algorithms
are cool or what makes algorithms cool
if you remember we had at the last
workshop we had this discussion
or the panel discussion and then
valentin asked a very nice question and
the question was
okay look so we are doing complexity
here so what happen if all computation
complexities
will sit in one plane and then this
plane will crash
will this be a loss for the society
and there were different opinions on
that so somehow yeah
but so so personally i would be very
upset and
not just because there are a lot of nice
people in this plane but also because
of because of a computational complexity
i am able to prove that what i am doing
is
cool and what i'm doing is tough because
if i design an algorithm and i cannot
improve it
still there is a very good chance that
by using complexity i would be able to
say
look no one else also can improve this
algorithm
and this is uh so this kind of a
philosophical
or this makes a very very very strong
changes in what we are doing
as algorithms theoreticians because
basically uh
lower bounds are always cool for us and
uh but uh and what what
really this area of exact algorithms
is missing is the accompany complexity
theory because
when i do an approximation algorithms i
have a very powerful tools
and this is very easy to argue that look
what i'm doing is
tough i cannot no one else can improve
it for exact algorithms i have a
branching algorithm
yes i i i i have a running time say 1.6
to the n
and then but is it cool or not i i
really don't know because maybe someone
in two years someone will come and say
look i have a better algorithm runs in
time 1.4 to the end
it's a term of course people try to
build the
complexity theory for exact algorithms
but here things become
very very hot especially if you try to
do it for subset problems
so for example there is actually a one
only exceptional walker which is built
on strong
eth lower bounds and this is actually
even very surprising that these people
manage to do
something there because if you start
thinking on uh reductions from one and
two complete problem to another
so if you say do reductions from sat
we we we almost never have a reduction
where for example
in these reductions we keep the same
number of variables as say the number of
vertices
right and and this is somehow makes it
really hard to
to build this exact uh lower bounds
and for example there are like uh
annoying things
so for example we know that we can solve
a click
in time like 1.19 to the n
but uh can we show that there is some
constant
such that we cannot solve click in
running time
c at this constant power n for example
even simple things which we somehow do
not understand
so in this talk i want to talk not about
subset problems i want to speak about
permutation problems which are solvable
by brute force in n factorial
and the most typical problem for the
permutation problem is hamiltonian cycle
of course partition problems where the
brute force takes
end to the end and the typical
problem is uh so here at graph coloring
and
also i will speak about problems where
even uh
stranger than permutation and partition
and where brute force takes an
even larger even takes
worse time and my first example of the
problem is
graph homomorphism
problem so graph homomorphism problem is
defined as follows
graph homomorphism is a mapping i have
two graphs g and h
and then there is a mapping from vertex
set of graph g
to vertices of graph h and basically the
condition i want to keep that for every
age of
that every age of graph g is mapped to
an h of graph h
if such a mapping exists then i say that
graph
g has a homomorphism to graph h
so one of the most famous example of
graph homomorphisms if we
take a look of a homomorphism of graph g
to a complete graph
t or kt on t vertices then
there is a homomorphism from g to
complete graph on t vertices if and only
if
graph g is t colorable
and it's uh easy to see and this is
actually why this problem is so popular
in
for graph theoreticians because whatever
so they just like to graph coloring and
this is also natural generalization of
graph coloring because if instead of a
complete graph
in the right hand of uh on the right
side of homomorphism we take any graph h
we can define h coloring of a graph g
and there is a lot of work of on graph
theory there's a whole book of
hello nation trill on this topic from
computational complexity this is also
interesting problem because
there was also quite old result of hell
in nature trail
which says that the problem of deciding
if there is a homomorphism from graph g
to graph h
is in p if and only if graph h
is bipartite and of course unless p
is not equal np
yeah so in one direction it's quite easy
right so if graph
h is bipartite then if graph g
has a odd cycle we never can map
odd cycle into bipartite graph
homomorphic
and if graph g is bypass then we can
just can map the whole graph into one h
of graph
h but they
converse direction is a much less
trivial
so this is a quite cute and nice paper
and actually it was also so
if you're interested in fine grain a
kind of analysis of this type of
algorithms it's also possible to show
that the graph homomorphism is not
subexp cannot be solved in sub
exponential time
or so basically
you can extend this result also not to p
and np but also p
and sub exponential type solubility and
basically the way to do it one of the
ways to do it is just to go very
carefully
to through the proof of calculation
trail or
yeah there can be other proofs of this
result
and um
the other way of looking at uh
homomorphism and this is uh the
the the way of looking at homomorphism
which was strongly advocated by leslie
lawrence so in his
later in his last book there's a the
whole chapter devoted to graph
homomorphisms and basically
what he's saying that it's very
convenient to look at different types of
homophysics and what he means by that so
basically
graph homomorphism is a different
problem depending if
the graph h is larger than the graph g
and this is the left
hand homomorphism and then because for
example if graph g is small and graph h
is large
so what is the kind of typical problem
can be encoded as a graph homomorphism
so for example if graph g is a click
and graph h is huge then basically if
there is a homomorphism from
g to h this is the same as if
there is a click of size
g in graph h so this is kind of a click
problem
on the other hand if the graph g is huge
and the graph h is small
then it's become different problem it's
a kind of graph coloring problem so
for example if h is a triangle then it's
a
three coloring so there are like two and
it looks like it's completely different
problems
and
it seems that you need a kind of
different types of approaches to solve
these problems
so first of all what is the brute force
for graph homomorphism so
if so the brute force for gram for graph
homomorphism is just this
time
so just for every vertex of gravity what
we are trying to do
we try all possible mapping into the
graph h
and this is exactly the amount of
mapping what we have
and then the natural question is uh if
there is a single exponential
type of algorithms and for some classes
of graphs yes of course there is some
single exponential algorithms for
example with the joint block with
spinara and data crutch
we show that uh if graph h is of bounded
trivets for example or of bounded degree
then there is a single exponential
algorithm
also this result was extended by magnus
vallestrom who showed that if the graph
h is of bounded cliques
then also there is a single exponential
algorithm for graph homomorphism
and this is a result on liquids is quite
nice because it immediately generalizes
the results on graph coloring
because graph coloring is a mapping to a
click click is of bounded clique with
so this is immediately shows
on the other hand if you take the
extreme case of graph
homomorphism graph coloring then again
so there's a brute force
for graph coloring is end to the end
but it was known from 1970s that we can
do coloring
much faster so there was a result of
flower from 1972
and then also this was recently not so
recently
improved by jordan russell and kovista
yes so and also if you speak about uh
left-hand side homomorphism or
about click problem in parameterized
complexity uh so the the
there were results which explaining that
uh for this type of homomorphisms
you cannot do it better than uh running
time
the age to the g basically
so up to exponential time hypothesis
but uh what about the right hand
homomorphism so for
so for graph coloring we have single
exponential algorithms
and graph homomorphism is a
generalization of this type of
result if there is also single
exponential algorithm for this type of
problem
and what of warning here is that
it's not it was not clear a priori if
there is a such type of algorithms or a
node
and basically in 2008 so traction
applied
particle translation proved a very nice
and cute result about g2 csp so g2csp is
a csp
where the size of domain is d and
the size of constrain is 2. so basically
what you show us that for this type of
g2 csp there's no algorithm of running
time
d power small of n again up to
exponential time hypothesis
and because graph homomorphism is
somewhere in between
of these two problems so where it will
fall it was open for some time
and basically i i want to sketch a proof
of the ethereum which was proved
together with sasha golovkinov sasha
kulikov and
vinay mehlen quite recently that unless
exponential time hypothesis fails
so homomorphism from graph g to h cannot
be solved in time
number of viruses of h power small of
number of vertices of a graph
g
so our reduction is from three coloring
so three coloring of course it's known
to be complete to be imp complete and
also it's
not known not to have a exponential time
sub exponential algorithm
up to eth but also you can always reduce
this result or tighten these results by
making a classical reduction from gary
johnson's
from graphs of arbitrary degree to
degree at most four
so three coloring uh on graphs at most
of the atmosphere can be solved and sub
exponential time
up to each and the idea is the following
so i want to reduce
three coloring to at least graph
homomorphisms and then from
at least graph homomorphisms will go to
graph homomorphisms so this graph
homomorphism
is an extension of graph homomorphisms
basically i also for every vertex
of the for vertices of the graph i also
have a list which says
which works is allowed to map to which
vertices
so it's like at least graph coloring so
we know that
for graphical for graph coloring there's
no single there's no sub exponential
algorithms
this this reduction i want to sketch and
also
the reduction from these homomorphisms
to graphomorphisms i probably will
skip
so how to go from three coloring to
least homomorphisms of the graph
graphs so suppose i have a instance of a
three coloring
graph on n vertices and i want to
construct a
instance of at least graph homomorphisms
where i i select uh some parameter r
and then uh the number of viruses in the
graph g prime is uh
n over r and then the number of vertices
of
in a graph h prime is d power r
where d is some constant
yes and then uh first of all why this
liama holds so that if i am able
to prove this lemma that i'm not able to
do this
homomorphism in this time well
this just holds because if i if i have
an algorithm for least homophilism
of the of certain running time if i just
plug in the numbers in the running time
of this algorithm then i also i will
obtain single
sub exponential algorithm for graph
coloring
and how to prove this uh kind of lemma
well i will just
give a sketch or a wave my hands uh by
proving a slightly
weaker assumption so instead of proving
that the size of the graph is
of d power r i will prove it for
this amount so uh if i if i prove it
for for this bound i will get a bit a
big
weaker statement but it's much easier
to get yes so so what happened and the
proof goes
uh up to some specific tricks for that
problem
it's kind of common proof for many
problems which
for which we want to prove that this
problem can be solved in certain time up
to exponential time hypothesis so what
we are doing
so we have an input graph g which one
the graph which you want to color
and then we split this graph into groups
of size r
each so and we just
identify all vertices in each group
in one vertex but we still keep
adjacency between the sets
so so here is example i had a graph
i i i i split it into groups of size two
and then i have a new graph which keeps
adjacency relation and so in in this new
graph every
vertex is a group of the original graph
and then basically what i want to do i
want to construct the graph h prime
such that if when i have a graph
homomorphism from graph
g prime to h prime so then this
homomorphism will immediately give me
proper 3 coloring of my original graph
this is what i want to do
yes so the idea is well for every
group of viruses of graph g prime so the
mapping to h prime should corresponds to
three coloring all the vertices
but also i want to keep the colorings or
all possible carrying colorings of the
neighborhoods because the graph coloring
is a
local problem so if i have a coloring
which is a proper
for every neighborhood of a vertex then
this is also
globally proper coloring so the only
thing i have to be careful
i have to be careful to see that this
coloring is proper for every
neighborhood of the eurex
so this basically means that i for every
vertex i have to keep a
track of all possible colorings three
colorings
of the set of vertices in the set which
is three power
r and also i have to keep all possible
colorings of the neighborhoods
so basically this gives me the running
or the size of my graph
of uh so for for every so for every
vertex of the graph
h prime i have to keep a huge list
of something of other
r power r labels and with this type of
power
with this type of labels i am label i am
able to identify
so not only the coloring of the vertex
but also i want to keep all possible
colorings of the neighborhood of the
groups around
the theoretics so the only trick which i
still
need to be which i still need here
is that there can be situation that uh
several neighbors
in graph g prime can be mapped in this
in the same vertex in graph h prime
so this somehow will be quite bad for me
because i won't be able to recover three
coloring out of that
but there is a trick here because why
and this is the trick why we need
the coloring on graphs of bounded degree
because when we have a graph of boundary
degree when we construct our graph g
prime so we take groups of vertices and
we contract this vertices into our
single vertices
still degree of this graph is bounded by
some constant times
r right and even if i take uh the square
of this graph or
still this the the the degree of this
square will be
of order r square which means that i
if i do some kind of video coloring on
this algorithm i'm still able to color
this graph in like
like r square plus one colors
and these colors i can use other labels
in my list and to control that uh no
collapse in the mapping
of the neighborhoods will occur that's
why i need lists
and and with using this trick it's
possible to
to prove the dilemma
yes so that was a little bit of hand
waving and then we still need to go from
at least homomorphisms to normal
homomorphism
which requires some work but this is
doable so basically what what happens to
unless exponential time hypothesis fails
we cannot solve homomorphisms in this
running time
so number first of age power small
o from number of viruses of g
so the next problem which is uh come
next is the problem of
subgraph isomorphism so here what i want
to do i have two graphs and i want to
decide if one graph g is a sub graph of
the graph h
and this is again this is a kind of a
generic problem it's uh of course it's
uh
hemingtonicity is a special case of that
problem
click the special case of this problem
so we can uh
define the various packing problem for
example if i want to
find the maximum number of vertical
joint triangles in my graph
it's still a special case of subgraph
isomorphism
even more exotic problems like
bandwidths of a graph so when i want to
find the
optimal labeling of the vertices of the
graph which minimize dilation over every
age
bandwidth is a special case of subgraph
isomorphisms
when graph g is arbitrary graph and
graph h is a
specific graph which is a k power of a
path
so it's a so this is quite generic
problem
and for subgraph isomorphism again so if
we look for brute force
so brute force photograph isomorphism
will be probably again
something like n power and because what
we do we just try for every
vertex of a graph of g we want to see
where this vertex can be mapped into
graph h
and in also very recently marek jacob
and arcadios
they proved how this uh problem of
subgraphic is morphism
can be solved faster than brute force
and the idea of the proof is the
following so reduction is from graph
homomorphisms to graph subgraph
isomorphisms okay
suppose that we have a instance of graph
homomorphism
here and suppose also that for some
reason i know that
i know how many for every vertex of
graph h
i know how many vertices of graph g are
mapped to this vertex
i don't know in which order and i know
sorry i don't know which vertices are
maps but i only guess the number of
vertices
this guess i'm allowed to do because uh
the possible number of uh
partitions is something like c to the n
or two to the n
for the services so this this guess i'm
allowed to do
okay but if i'm allowed to do this what
i'm doing i constructed this
the new graph so so what happened here
so if i have a homophilism from here to
here
i construct a graph where every vertex
in a graph h i replace by independent
set
and the size of the independent set is
exactly the number which is which i
guess
how many vertices will be marked from g
to h
that's it right because then what's
happening
i know that the graph g is the sub graph
of graph
h prime subject to this guess
if and only if there is a homomorphism
from graph g to h
prime so basically my reduction is then
i take all possible guesses so i
branch in like two to the n cases it's
still single exponential
and then if i'm able to solve at least
in one of them subgraph isomorphism i am
able to solve
graph homomorphism if i am able to solve
graph homomorphisms i am able to solve
sat and
exponential time which is
the end of the story so we can
conclude that unless the exponential
time hypothesis fails deciding if graph
g the sub graph of h cannot be done
in time 2 to the small of n log n where
n is the number of years in the graph
h well
and it appears because homomorphism and
sub graphical mathematicians are quite
powerful problems and you can also play
a lot with them
to prove new and new low bounds for
different problems on graphs
so for some of the problems things go
just almost for free
for example so the quadratic assignment
problem is a quite popular problem and
operation research
and incremental optimization there is
even book on quadratic assignment
so basically the problem is i have two
matrices and then i
ask to find a permutation of matrix so
matrices w
and d and i want to find a permutation
in matrix d
which optimizes minimizes or maximizes
the following sum
this is a special case it's easy to see
of subgraph isomorphism
so therefore for example another problem
which was study a lot but
in graph theory there was a called
impetition this is the problem of
feather hellclan and motroni
so the problem is the following i have a
matrix m
and this matrix is tell me how should i
uh partition the vertices of my graph
so when uh so basically for every
one it means that there should be all
edges present
for every zero it say that there should
not be edges at all and for every star
say i don't care so for example coloring
will be
so i put on in matrix m on a diagonal i
put all zeros so basically that should
be independent
sets and all other elements should be i
don't care should be star
and also this problem is if you take
matrix m as a
adjacency matrix of the graph and the
homomorphism then there's a homomorphism
from one graph to another if and only if
so there is such
a partition corresponding to this matrix
so again this matrix is again
this problem is again special case of
sub of graph homomorphism
graph minus graph minor graph g is a
minor of graph
h if we can obtain graph g from h by
deleting
vertices deleting edges or contracting
edges so here is example of a
graph minor so here are the cells which
we want to
contract and basically again so what's
happening so
the the the the low bound for
homomorphisms and for some graphics
mappings it works even for the case when
graph g and graph h
they have the same number of vertices
but then a graph minor is a stupid case
of
graph isomorphism because basically if i
have two graphs on the same vertex set
and i ask if one graph is a minor of the
of another i'm not allowed to contract
edges
so the only thing i can do i can delete
edges
and in this case it's again i cannot
solve the problem in single exponential
time
so graph minor goes for free and similar
like topological graph minor shallow
graph minor
actually so the same low bounce hole and
actually
any kind of graph modification problem
you you take where you have to delete
edges and plus
do something this type of reduction
shows that
all these types of problems can be
solved in
uh single exponential time on graphs
okay so one of the exceptions from this
kind of
world of graph modification problem it
can be a little bit artificial problem
but still people study this type of
problems
so if i have two graphs and i ask if i
can obtain one graph
just by contracting ages
from another graph and because this type
of reduction doesn't work here and
actually
that's a kind of so most likely again
the
this problem shouldn't be solved in a
single exponential time but still
for this problem we don't know or i i
don't know what's happening for this
problem so that's an
open question so the other question is
also kind of uh
dihotomy type or characterization types
of problems so if you consider the
problem
so when we play with the
right hand graph h so we fix the graph h
or we fix
some classes of graphs from graph h and
then we can see the all possible mapping
from
all graphs to this class of graphs so
then we know some kind of some single
exponential types of algorithms here
for example when graph h is a click
then it's coloring right then we know
that there's a single exponential
algorithm
more generally it's easy to extend if
graph h is a perfect graph
for example or a graph h of bounded
degree
of bounded credits
clicknets but it will be very
interesting to
to to have a kind of a dichotomy type of
result saying
it's a kind of hell natural dichotomy
saying
look for this class of graphs h there is
a single exponential time algorithm
and for this type of class of graphs h
it doesn't exist
so far is i even don't have any
reasonable hypothesis
how this graph h should look like
because so far
this class is a they do not seem to have
anything
in common right so graphs of perfect
graphs graphs of boundary degree graphs
of bounded cliques
yeah so what's happening here any kind
of characterization will be just nice
and cute
so and here the other question is also
like uh
for the question about uh
dichotomy of csp it's also so far we
know the running times
of two to the n or two to the n log n
roughly right
is there any kind of uh running time
between them for some classes of graph h
this we also don't know right even this
type of result saying look for
for any class graph for any class of
graphs h you either have single
exponential
or you have n to the log n
that's another question yes so this type
of hell natural
theorem is definitely is missing here
so the symmetric questions can be asked
for when we speak about homophysics from
the other side so
like a kind of click type of questions
so here it's yes and uh and and actually
well you also it's also will be
interesting to play not only for fixing
g
or fixed and h but fixing or two of them
are to see what's happening here
so it's kind of yeah so so that question
about fine grain complexity here
so so our proofer
so our low bound photographer
homomorphisms it can be extended not
just for some graphs uh
and g and h actually the way we prove it
we prove proved that if you take
any function h as a polynomial of
the number of errors in graph g then you
can say
the same low bound holes for graph
homomorphisms
and basically uh well it looks like
uh we know that uh homophisian from
graph
g and h is solvable in this running time
h power b
of g for any values or of or of any
dependence h of g
and basically that's it you cannot do
anything better unless
exponential time hypothesis fails but
for example if you
pick up another favorite problem graph
minus
so what's happening here so we know by
robertson seymour
resolve that if graph g
is very small then we can solve the
problem in times
f of g times h cube and i think now
there are results improving h cube plus
h square
and it's not clear if you can improve it
to h log h or
but still some polynomial of h so
that's for small g that's what we know
and we also know that for light g
is followed from our reduction right
that the running time should be
h of g so what for example happening
when g is a square root of h for example
it's it looks like a huge gap on our
understanding
what's happening for small graphs and
what's happening for large graphs
and anything in between is completely
open so for example
how many functions characterize the
complexity of this problem is it one
function two functions
ten countable number of functions
nothing is clear here
yes so nothing in between yes so the
other so
is this so there are more specific
problems so basically
can we decide if uh some graph either
more feasible
when the sub graph g is of degree 3 can
be done
in one of these times so why i'm asking
this question because
if graph g is of degree 2 then it's a
hamiltonicity
so we can do it in 2 to the h running
time just
add a little bit to hamiltonicity what's
happening here
still we don't know anything
yes and uh the note is that if graph g
is of small trivets then some graph
isomorphism can be solved from by doing
some dynamic programming and inclusion
exclusion so this is
kind of doable yes
so the the very similar question is
about the automatic characterization for
subgraph
isomorphism now so what happened so what
happening for different value or
for different classes of h and g is it
possible to
where is the border of tractability or
well tractability or where is the mode
of single exponential tractability
for this type of problems again yes
now i will go i i still have like 10
minutes right or
yeah and then i what i want to do
somehow
i want to go through different uh my
favorite
well it's very biased list of problems
but i would call like my favorite
problems on graphs
and for each of these problems still
there are a lot of questions which
somehow
i don't understand what's happening here
so the first problem is metric embedding
so i have two metrics
just maybe say two graph metrics and i
have a
and i ask if there is embedding of one
metric into another with distortion at
most d
what does it mean so i'm looking for a
metric say that this is
an embedding is embedding is
non-contracting
so for every
so so non-contracted means that the
distance in the original graph is always
at least the distances
in this graph and also distortion is at
most d that means that uh the distances
in the
uh in the new graph they are always at
most
they are always at most d times the
distances in the
original graph okay so what uh
is here again so the first of all the
same thing uh
the trig box uh reduction from subgraph
isomorphism right because
if i have two graphs g and h with the
same number of viruses
then if there is no contracting a
bearing of graph g into graph
h it's if and only if graph h
is a sub graph of graph g right so just
because i'm strongly using the property
that the embedding should be
non-contractive
okay this means that unless exponential
time hypothesis fails finding the
minimum distortion
bearing of graph g into energy vertex
graph h cannot be done in this
running time what will happen the
distances here
sorry what happened to distances what do
you mean
so distances don't contract you want to
get like essentially
minimum i want to find yes if there is
any rate because for
if one graph is not a graph of the other
you cannot have non-contracting
embedding at all right
yeah but what about the distances so
what will happen to distances do we have
weights on the edges no no so so far
there's no weights so
this is even phenomenal so the lower
bound is for non-weighted
case
yes and well
if a graph if we embed into specific
type of metrics for example if we embed
into a path
then it's possible to do it uh how then
it's possible to do
this embedding into single exponential
running time so this is
requires some work but uh again
embarrassing uh
is embarrassing but for example we don't
know what's happening if you want to
embed a graph into a cycle metric
from path to cycle
binary tree or maybe it will be easier
to show low bounce if you want to in
better grad
and better graph not into a cycle but
into grid for example
but still actually nothing beyond paths
is known
so the other favorite problem is a tree
spanner so i have a graph again and say
an elevated graph and then i'm looking
for a spanning tree which preserves
distances in graph g with a ratio at
most
t right
so for this problem actually uh i don't
know anything better
than a brute force so probably so the
brute force is
i try all possible set of ages and then
uh
for or i go through all spawning trees
and for each spawning tree i
i'm checking this condition so but
anything better
i don't know so the other favorite
problem is
bandwidth so bandwidth i have a graph
and i want to find
if there is a numbering of uh from 1 to
n which optimize dilation over ages
right or equivalently we can see that
we can embed not in a path but in a
power of a path
so this problem is solvable in single
exponential time so there was a result
of five again killian
and then there was several improvement
on the running time of this algorithm
but for example if we go back to 1970s
there there are people studying bandits
was one of the most favorite problem
in in many areas and people will study
for example the parameters
which are called two bandwidths so
basically instead of a path i want to
embed a graph on a grid
or if you think in terms of labeling i
want to label every vertex with a
pair of labels what's happening for this
variant of the problem
is it's still solvable in some
exponential time or remote generally
if we consider if you embed now
our graph not into a grid but into a
g-dimensional grid
yes graph meets and this is a kind of a
joke which was uh like
at the boot camp so daniel marx in his
first talk
he was saying or should i repeat this
joke or uh
yeah maybe okay okay maybe a good joke
should be repeated four times so
basically what's happening here daniel
marks was teaching trivia and his slides
and basically he said okay i will never
define you trivits but then the next
lecture he was using this definition
recursively and recursively
and also i'm just
also want to use the definition of
trivis here recursively so
yes so yes so when we speak about
different types of decompositions of the
graph like bandwidth trivias paths cut
with
rank widths most of these problems are
doable in single exponential running
time
so some of them are
quite pedestrians like catholics or for
parties for tributes or for bandwidth
it requires some thinking and for rank
it's it's it's awesome
but uh one of the notable
exceptions in in this set of problems is
branch with so what are the branches so
what is a
branch decomposition i
with my graph i want to associate a
binary tree and to the leaves of this
tree i want to associate
the edges of my graph and then if i take
any cut in this tree this cut in the
tree it corresponds to the partition of
the edges on my original graph right
and then the measure of this cut is the
number of vertices which separate
one set from the vertices from the other
and then i'm looking for the best type
of
decomposition of my graph and here the
kind of brute force algorithm is again 2
to the power but number of edges m
and just this parameter is so close to
trivets it's a kind of constant fact
approximation of triggers
but still it's kind of unclear if you
can do it vertex exponential
and the other kind of strange problem is
the cliques problem so i really don't
know what will be the brute force
algorithm for clickers probably some
kind of
guessing partitions again guessing
permutations and things
like that but if anyone knows any
algorithm for clickers or how
to okay we will
or forget about click this because we
even don't know how to compute the
cliques of
at most four in a graph right so but
still it will be interesting
to see what kind of algorithms can be
for clickers
another set uh goes from topological
problems
so topological problems uh what are the
genus of the graph
right so
what are the genus of the graph i i have
a graph and i am asking if i can embed
my graph
into the surface of the minimum genus
such that there's no intersections
or if i can embed my graph without
intersections of edges into the surface
right well
there was a algorithm to power big of
g times n which was announced in the
paper of uh kaneshikorobayashi boy mohr
and bruce reed in 2008
where they say that actually the
algorithms they give
also works in this running time
but somehow still this type of algorithm
even if it works
it doesn't give us a two to the n
running time because the genus of a
graph if if embeds are complete to embed
complete graph into surface
we need something we need basically we
need a handle for every age
so basically it's something like n
square over two the genus of this of the
complete graph
so basically even with this type of
algorithm we still don't have a single
exponential algorithm
but if it works i don't know because
it's it's still
it's it's it's it's in i think it's fox
uh conference proceedings
it's 10 pages and i haven't seen the
full proof that's what i mean
we don't continue this write-offs okay
okay so the other favorite problem is
also very classical problem is a book
thickness of a graph
so basically i want a better graph into
p pages so what do you mean what do i
mean by embed
i want to embed vertices on a spin of
the book
and then on every age and every every
every page of the book i embed
ages such that they do not overlap so
basically on every page
this is an autoplanograph so
there was a for to if i want to embed my
graph into two pages then this graph
should be planar
and basically you can reduce the problem
to the
tsp problem on planar graphs and
it's possible to solve this problem in
two power square root of n
running time but already for p equal to
three
things become much more mysterious and
basically uh
yeah so book thickness is another
open question so so far the trivial
algorithm would be
because the problem is even and complete
if i give you the ordering of the
vertices on the spine
it is so so then the trivial algorithm
will be
i guess an ordering of the vertices
something like n factorial
then i guess partitioning of the ages
well for fixed p
i have that the number of asia should be
linear as a number of viruses
but that's still very far from single
exponential or
so so here we don't know anything and
the final set of vertices again is
also a favorite set of uh graph coloring
problems
so the the most uh annoying question
here is
age coloring so basically h coloring is
a kind of from approximation algorithms
it's very simple problem right because
it's always i have a additive
factor one approximation for this right
it's either degree or a degree plus one
but if you if you look for exact
algorithm for these problems
so the best known algorithm for this
problem i know
is uh i construct lh graph of my graph
and then
i run the bjorklund husfelca vista
algorithm
for graph coloring on that which gives
me like 2 to power m
so basically the only running time we
know is 2 power
n square and that's it right so anything
better for this problem
so also what happening for list coloring
or a key usability so basically
i want to identify the minimum size of
the
list which i can assign to the vertices
of a graph such that for any
least coloring of this uh graph
i would be able for every assignment of
list i would be able to pick up
the proper coloring for that so here yes
i guess
so here i also don't know anything for
that
and also there's another line or area of
research where people doing kind of
radial coloring problems so basically
radio colorings problems where also
colorings is not local but it depends uh
also on distances from so so here
also a lot of interesting problems and
basically a story indicates that i
should stop
in like a few minutes and basically i
want to conclude
with this so this is a landscape taken
by
uh expl uh the landscape of mars
and basically this is also what's
happening now it will be very
interesting
and exciting to explore what's happening
with this kind of permutation and
partitioning problems on graphs
so far we're really able to indicate
several kind of
not mountains but maybe hills of
interactability there
but still for almost any reasonable
problem there we still know next to
nothing
and basically i i think that it's a kind
of exciting program
and yeah and thank you very much
thank you very much for taking the time
to have some kind of survey and as an
introduction
questions comments protests
yeah so from james problem you only need
to guess a rotation system right
all right you only need to guess a
rotation system yes this gives you
something like n factorial right
you have a lower bound for minor testing
to do it also for immersions
commercial i think the same trick
works right because for immersion
we just don't delete ages and then so so
so it's again it's like subgraph
isomorphism so if you have so
if you have two graphs of the same on
the same vertex set
right then it's a kind of subgraph
isomorphism it's a kind of silly
reduction because
what i mean by silly because yes we know
that for this special case it's like
that
but for more interesting cases like if
if one graph is of size squared of n of
the other graphs
we don't know anything so somehow no for
immersions
we also thought
you could parameterize that whole that
whole
setup you know you have n to the k and
k factorial and stuff like that other
franchises
versions of this program
in some sense you know it's known that
you can't have an
n to the k minus epsilon for k
dominating said unless fdt is equal to
m2
so you could kind of visit that whole
behavior
the answer is no and the reason is very
simple because even uh
so when you start parameterize things
you go much more and
advanced level of understanding right
and here we don't understand even
simple things well simple yes so
so definitely if you manage to settle
this type of questions that's that will
be the next step in the program
but yeah suffice
then let's thank the speaker again